the liberal media is not too happy about
Donald Trump's big night in Iowa major
Outlets like MSNBC and CNN flat out
refusing to air the former president's
victory speech after his historic
win I can't imagine why they think
that's a good thing Donald Trump
declaring Victory with a historically
strong showing in the Iowa caucuses the
projected winner of the Iowa caucuses um
has just started giving his victory
speech of course there is a reason that
we and other news organiz ations have
generally stopped giving an unfiltered
live platform to remarks by former
president trump it is not out of spite
it is not a decision that we relish and
when they were not censoring him pundits
had some very strong words for the
voters who supported him these are white
Christians that this is a state that is
over represent over represented by white
Christians you voted for a guy who said
come risk your lives for the grand
wizard come in the snow and the sleep
because I am more important than your
life it's that the Trump has in some
ways become religion for a certain
section of the American electorate and
especially for evangelicals that it's
not about the virtue anymore it's about
the vice that Trump expresses 19% so I
think we're all sitting
here disgusted that they would vote for
someone like this and how's this first
been Democrats trying to make the case
that the biggest victory in Iowa caucus
history history is somehow a bad thing
for the former president first of all
5050 for an incumbent really sucks um
this is not good for Donald Trump I
don't care how they spin it 49% is not
great for him actually in a in
electorate in a lot of these future
States and half the people in that party
didn't vote for Donald Trump so I think
that is telling it tells you the
weakness of Donald Trump trump swept
Iowa no he did not he he he swept 5% of
the population only 133% of registered
Republicans in the state of Iowa 133% of
the party showed up these are small
numbers and it's very important to
remember that judge seeing that you had
so many clear off- camera reactions to
what we just heard jump in there I mean
what I I am so tired of these people
being so disgusted because 73 million
people voted for Donald Trump they are
disgusted that's the word they use that
we exercise our right to vote I am
disgusted that someone is angry that
white Evangelical Christians voted for
Donald Trump these are people who work
hard who have the right to vote who have
the right to vote for whomever they want
to and who the hell are you to be
disgusted by them you know I'm tired of
the censorship I'm tired of Rachel mat
saying you know the projected winner
we're not going to we're not going to
air what he has to say she can't even
say his name and then you've got Tapper
saying we've got an anti-immigrant in
you know person running for president
the truth is we've got 2 and A2 million
illegals you can call them migrants all
you want they're illegal aliens half a
million are are ones who are um the
unaccounted for and then another half a
million that were gotway so we've got
three and a half million and we should
just be happy about it and finally Larry
O'Donnell saying the only reason Haley
didn't win is because she's not a
warmonger excuse me she was on the board
to boing and you know these people are
so hateful and yet the United States
Supreme Court is about to rule on the
Biden Administration and the fact that
this case I think it's uh Miry against
the state of Missouri because they
literally are censoring us and
suppressing the free speech and they say
Trump is Hitler the Supreme Court is now
going to decide whether or not they were
involved not just in the suppression of
the 2020 election in that laptop which
we know based upon people who voted they
would have changed their vote which
would have allowed Trump to win but it
was a coordinated campaign by the
Democrats by the White House by federal
officials to impact social media whether
it's Facebook YouTube or X to make sure
that we are censored that our private
speech is censored I mean Harold is it a
problem that I mean this was a historic
win for the former president I will last
night that if you're one of the voters
in Iowa who supported him in the
caucuses that you couldn't even tune
into those other networks to watch his
victory speech yes I think it was a
mistake not not to do that I I don't
like censoring um um Fox when President
Biden speaks rightly so he's the
president of United States you you you
listen to the president you have the
leading candidate on the other side the
first in the nation's voting happens I
don't get that one two I I think people
some of the voices that we heard some of
them I know some some of the people I
know some I don't know um they're just
wrong this is amateur politics you're
practicing if you believe that you begin
to dissect how many people voted uh how
many Republicans voted I think Donald
Trump uh is likely to be the nominee for
the Republican party uh you're not going
to beat him by saying that people who
support him are bad people or they're
not good people and you're not going to
beat him by not putting him on
television you got to have a better
message and you got to understand
something Sandra you said at the be at
the outset in your remarks and I think
Greg did as well
uh and we tried to say a little bit last
night these are everyday issues that
people are concerned about in this race
uh our politics is broken so as a result
our border is broken our government is
broken from the standpoint of being able
to do the basic things that people want
them to do our schools our neighborhoods
our workplaces even our places of
worship which by definition means rural
and urban Americans alike their lives
are in bit in disrepair and what what
Donald Trump is doing uh he's speaking
to that and the way you beat that is not
censoring not not talking about it not
criticizing his supporters but we need a
better message and I think we could
develop one but this is not the way to
do it Bessie remember in the ' 80s when
the hip-hop album came out and they put
that warning explicit material parental
advisory on it it made me want to buy it
and that's what they're doing at CNN and
MSNBC it just makes you want to watch
what you're not allowed to we're big
boys we're big girls we don't need
parental control features on a news
channel and what kind of business model
is a news channel where they don't take
live news that's not very smart Jake
Tapper cuts the guy off when he starts
mentioning immigration the number one
policy issue in Iowa when you vote for a
guy and he wins and then he speaks
afterwards to the voters that's like the
connective tissue in democracy you can't
save democracy by censoring democracy
and then Mata is coming out and acting
like she's trying to protect the network
from lawsuits to justify the censorship
because oh someone might say something
that's not true she's like the lead hoax
her she did the Russia hoax the labtop
the letter the lab Le cover up all of it
and then Joy it's over represented by
white Christians so what this is a
majority white country majority
Christian country overrepresented
compared to the rest of the country okay
well South Carolina is over represented
by black Christians New York's over
represented by atheists and Jews
California's over represented by
Hispanics Joy re
the history these politicians have to go
around to all of these diverse
geographical areas and try to get a very
broad Coalition together demographically
religiously broad that's how politics
works now the other
guy it's Trump had a bad night Biden
rigged his own primary Biden kicked JFK
Jr out of the party and then cancelled
New Hampshire there's this is not this
is a good night for Donald Trump right
can we uh can we put Joy Reed back up
there you know I was looking U at Joy
Reed I'm thinking you know my
brother-in-law when we we we used to go
to 49 games he he's big 49er fan he used
to paint his face you know gold and
silver and you can tell that Joy Reid is
totally in Trump's Camp because she's
wearing his hair and I think that's a
sign she knew he was going to win she
wanted to be on The Winning Side look at
that that's uh that's uh Trump's her and
Clay Travis's Blazer yes exactly look
you know the um the thing that
what's always interesting is how little
self-examination these people do they're
like a they're like ET a sketch right
they they write all these things in
their little brain and create this
hysteria predict things that will never
happen then they shake their head and
it's all gone and then they start over
again both sides left and right traffic
in apocalyptic pronouncements and in in
some cases demonization but there's a
key difference here the liberal media's
argument is all prediction right the
right median media is usually based on
evidence right we have the crime wave
the border the attack on science
targeting of parents the military white
supremacy hoax domestic terrorism the
suppression of speech these are things
that you don't have to predict they're
right there so the media will say and
all they can say is Trump will do X
Trump will do y but all you got to do is
go like yeah but look at the border
crisis look at the fact that you removed
punishment from uh from criminals look
at you know look at how you lied about
climate to push a destructive agenda
those aren't predictions those are facts
ah very good discussion it is more
coming up GRE thank you I had President
Biden Tak taking swings at the mega
movement after Trump dominated hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else